the Joe Rogan experience did you know
that PETA kills thousands of dogs but
I've heard any time I post anything
about PETA I have a bunch of people
saying they're the worst well they're
not the worst but what they are is
they're the the origins of PETA is the
Animal Liberation Organization the the
origins of PETA the people that
originally founded PETA believed that
all animals including pets should be
free they don't believe in domesticated
animals okay and well that's
preposterous
yeah being a pet is the bet I've
actually said if I could be reincarnated
it would be a rich person's golden
retriever I've said that I didn't
realize your dog is what I want to come
back at it's the best life the best life
that dog is only known love yeah what
stress happens in that dog's life
occasionally he can't go out like if I'm
injured or something like that for like
weeks at a time
but Peter kills animals because they
think that their policy is that it's
you're more free to be dead than you are
I don't know well I don't want to put
words number I think that's it they
definitely kill animals but they kill
them quick that's the thing they're not
out there trying to find owners form oh
yeah that's the knock on them the
knocking the Animal Liberation
Organization I mean they've like broken
into like they're the type of people
that like break into [ __ ]
supermarkets and release the lobsters
back to the ocean be free be free man
I'm into it so are you I'm into it I'm a
total vegan I know you're leading her I
know you are but those lobsters have
always made me so sad why they're bugs
do you swat mosquitoes I rarely kill
bugs when mosquitoes are [ __ ] you up
you just let him please divinely eat me
drink of my blood no you or me now I am
you and if you give me malaria then so
be it
I just okay maybe not like I'm not crazy
okay I've come over to your house your
house is filled with roaches I hand you
bug spray do you use it um yes because
roaches roaches can [ __ ] oh no I did
have an instance and this is true I was
in the shower and I was it was
I get really vegan and really when I'm
depressed I get more vegan than ever
it's like what throws me into it I'm
just feeling too much and then I feel
for every animal and it just gets out of
control so if I'm ever you know going
off about vegan propaganda on my
Instagram someone should check in on me
I'm in a dark place yes and one day I
was in the shower and there was a dying
house centipede like drowning the
grossest bug known to man like it's
there's a half centipede half spider
they're disgusting they've I don't hate
anything more than that creature and I
was like you know what I can't kill it I
want to save it and just take it outside
and I'll like tell my vegan friends like
I'll be like such a good vegan today so
I got out of the shower and like you and
you get out of the shower and you think
you're just like you just don't need a
towel I'm just gonna grab something and
you like traipse like a lazy river
throughout your house because just I did
that made a huge mess get a paper towel
come back and pick it up and I'm so
scared to do it and I and I like I'm so
proud of myself too I can't wait to
[ __ ] tell the vegans and I open and
I'm so scared because I want to see if
it's still alive and it was a clump of
pubes
it wasn't even oh yeah so I but which
looks exactly mine your pubes are that
dark I yeah dude yeah this is all bottle
it's a bottle a battle yeah I mean
they're not like dark dark but
centipedes house centipedes are like
blonde they're kind of like dirty blocks
you know that hair bleach is not vegan
right listen when I said that you like
oh [ __ ]
[Applause]